Joss Whedon's Firefly was poised to be the
next huge sci-fi series to change television.
Unfortunately, those hopes were dashed after
one incomplete season.
Let's look back at the reasons why Firefly's
lights went out.
A small, loyal fan base
Like Joss Whedon's other shows, Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and Angel, Firefly developed
a strong, dedicated fan base.
Unfortunately, the fans weren't in great enough
numbers to halt cancellation, despite letter-writing
campaigns to keep it alive.
Still, the show's abrupt ending shouldn't
be surprising, considering what happened before
it even began production...
Marriage Trouble
According to Business Insider, Fox's bigwigs
had a problem with two of the characters,
Zoe and Wash, being happily married.
Fox told Whedon to nix their marriage, or
they'd nix the deal.
Whedon revealed in the Firefly DVD commentary
that he stuck to his guns, saying, "Then don't
pick up the show, because in my show, these
people are married."
Ultimately, the execs backed down, and the
show made it to the airwaves, but that didn't
mean the troubles ended.
Friday Night Fright
Firefly was scheduled for Friday nights, better
known among TV fans as the "Friday night death
slot."
Now, airing on Friday nights doesn't automatically
predestine shows for early cancellation...unless
that show airs on Fox.
At over 30 television series, Fox has actually
cancelled more Friday night programs than
any other network.
Firefly had a death sentence right out of
the gate.
The episodes aired out of order
When Whedon conceived the show, he planned
it as an episodic-yet-continuous story divided
into hour-long chunks.
The episodes needed to air in a specific order
to make sense to viewers.
Somehow, this went over Fox execs' heads,
and each chapter of Firefly aired out of order
on Fox.
The pilot—which introduces the characters
and plot of the entire venture—didn't air
until the end of the show's run.
The promos didn't capture the spirit of the
show
Fox's ads, promos, and commercials for Firefly
failed at properly conveying what the show
was about or what it was in spirit.
As producer Chris Buchanan said on the DVD
commentary, the campaign "suggested [Firefly]
was a wacky genre comedy," when it wasn't.
And as author Amy Pascale wrote in Joss Whedon:
the Biography, viewers who would've loved
the show were too alienated to watch it, and
those who tuned in because of the promos were
disappointed.
Low ratings
With everything going against it, Firefly's
bad ratings were unsurprising.
On average, it attracted about 4.7 million
viewers.
While that's a huge number in and of itself,
it's puny by network television standards.
According to E! Online, Firefly finished at
98th place in the Nielsen ratings.
The show itself was excellent, but Fox only
cared about numbers.
An executive defense
Despite all the obstacles they placed before
the show's success, the folks at Fox essentially
played dumb when it came to Firefly's cancellation.
Former Fox Entertainment president Gail Berman
told the Pittsburgh Post-Gazette, "having
to cancel it was very difficult."
Must've been difficult...considering she was
part of the decision-making process that led
to the series' episodes airing out of order
and on Friday nights.
At least fans eventually got some closure
in the form of 2005's Serenity, the big motion
picture followup to the series.
That's better than some one-season wonders
ever get...
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know why
you think we lost Firefly too early...